In the Heat of a Barcelona Square a
rallying call for supporters of the
largest pro-catalan independence party
warning voters of the dangers to their
cause in the event of a right-wing
victory
in this region of seven and a half
million people that accounts for nearly
a fifth of Spain's economy Regional
autonomy has been the reality and for a
vocal section of society secession from
Spain Remains the goal
but after the failed 2017 bid for
Independence tensions between Barcelona
and Madrid provoked the most serious
crisis in Spain's recent history The
center-right People's Party then in
government arrested and tried leaders of
the Catalan independence movement and
took back full control when Pedro
Sanchez the leader of the Spanish
Socialist Workers Party became prime
minister in 2018 a new era of dialogue
was set in motion which led to a pardon
for the independence leaders
Sanchez's narrow majority in Parliament
for the past five years meant he has had
to rely on votes from both the Catalan
and Basque separatist parties to pass
legislation and it's this level of
cooperation they say that has led to
Effective Government
the majority of citizens want to
continue on this path they know the
future of Catalonia is about
understanding at that Spain progresses
the only way of maintaining this
progress is to keep Pedro Sanchez as
leader the
question is what's making the Prime
Minister look as the vulnerable
see the so the Socialist made gains here
in May's local elections his perceived
leniency towards Catalan separatist
politicians is being seen by unionist
across Spain as unforgivable the leader
of the People's Party has made several
campaign visits to the region stressing
Unity with Spain The People's Party will
create work wealth and maintain a fluid
dialogue with the Catalan society and we
will do so in respect of its particular
characteristics but placing importance
on the unity that Catalan share with the
rest of Spain a victory by The People's
Party would likely be propped up by
support from the far-right Vox party
which has vowed to come down hard on the
regional Independence movements while
this may be a gift for their unionist
supporters for separatists it would be
too much of a provocation Al Jazeera
Barcelona